luisa noibawa is a climate activist and
leading figure in the fridays for future
movement in germany and globally she
joins us today on dw miss noibawa thank
you for being with us
you've said recently that europe's
dependence on fossil fuels is the root
cause of the war in ukraine and that
europe should respond by radically
building up renewable energy what good
do you think that could do now in the
short term when i when i say that i'm
just looking at the situation right now
together with economists with
diplomats with wolf experts everywhere
who see that the dependency on
russian fossil fuels
is one
of the of the of the many things that
make poutine so powerful right now
um this isn't anything or this this
understanding of of the roots of of
putin's power hasn't to do anything with
the concrete actions that need to be
taken now we ukraine needs a solidarity
right now they need support from all
over europe they need what is needed to
protect them and that is very clear
yet while looking at the bigger picture
um we see it's important to to be honest
about who is financing parts of these
tax and that is germany for instance uh
you know who is you know getting half of
its energy from putin
we've
heard germany's finance minister
christian lindner who's not necessarily
one of friday's for futures best pals
say that renewable energy is the energy
of freedom do you think germany's
government shares your assessment in
terms of the need to push for renewable
energy now
well if they don't you know
get it now
that renewable energies aren't just the
greenest and cheapest kinds of energies
but also the most peaceful energy that
we have i wouldn't know what to wait for
i mean open your eyes it's out there um
it's a it's those fossil fuels imports
that
yeah that empower putin that finance
those rules and it's uh you know not too
hard to understand
that
democracies can't be truly free they
can't be truly sovereign and safe as
long as their energy supply depend on an
autocrat next door that has you know
obvious tendencies to start wars
we have a stark energy crisis on the
horizon
you call for massively building
renewable energies but now in germany
even green members of the government are
thinking of pushing back the phase out
of nuclear and coal it doesn't seem like
renewable energies are a viable solution
at least in the short term
energy experts tell different stories
and i think you know at this point it's
important to differentiate between
responses to a war and transformative
action that needs to be taken um you
know to get independent from fossil
fuels from putin and others
and we're seeing very clearly the
studies um tell a
very strong story about how of course we
can get 100 renewable
um yeah in the medium term and how
everything that we're doing now in terms
of energy action needs to have this
transformative character and this is not
the time to play games and this is not
the time to do some kind of symbolic
gestures
that fire and fuel conflicts like those
and of course at the same time and i
think it's important
to to highlight as much as possible
ukraine needs our support and that is
not just a question of energy diplomacy
where that's a question of solidarity of
peace actions of support that is needed
germany and other countries in europe
are however going to have to likely
bridge
the
decreasing amount of gas and oil or the
more expensive gas and oil
coming into the countries and it takes
time to build a big amount of renewable
energy sources is it acceptable then to
accept a pushback of of coal or even
nuclear at least in germany
well no of course not
we have
brought ourselves a government of border
valve in a very very tricky situation
where we are highly dependent on fossil
fuel imports from autocrats like poutine
and that has a cost
and the answer to that of course can't
be an increasing dependency on fossil
fuels but needs to be you know energy
independence and that is what we get
with the most democratic the most
peaceful the greenest the cheapest the
most
uh protecting kind of energy so that we
have and that is renewables and there is
a cost attached to that but cost is
attached to everything and the question
is just who bears a cost and how do we
handle it in a just way and that's of
course where the government is asked to
to make sure that those who can't afford
it get access to to clean and cheap
energy
as quickly as possible but that can
never be an excuse to delay any kind of
action at the same time the ipcc has
spoken a very strong language yesterday
again the climate crisis is escalating
and this is another time to not play out
the crises against each other but to
connect the dots and see the bigger
picture here
what do you think of uh the german
government's commitment to massively
invest in the military with a bill of up
to 100 billion euros i'm a climate
activist i
am
having our intention of getting involved
in uh
military or geo um politics discourse
that we have here in germany what we're
seeing though is that you know many
experts
are wondering where exactly all this
money is supposed to go and
uh when we will be at the point where
the government makes this money or
freezes money for things that are
actually transformative that actually
contribute to a more safe and more just
and
yeah more sustainable
society
you and fridays for future want germany
to become climate neutral by 2035 do you
think that is an achievable goal
especially in light of the war in
ukraine and what that means for the
energy market
well when we're writing those demands
we're not just writing random wishlist
wish lists that we you know that we just
come up with on an afternoon we talk to
experts we see what is possible if you
really want if you provide the political
will of you if you organize people
around a transformation towards climate
justice and yes of course it's possible
of course we can be renewable by
2035 and just yesterday the government
kind of hinted that they're actually
planning to transform some part of the
energy sector to an extent that that
part will be 100 renewables by 2035 we
see again and again and again we don't
have a lack of
technical possibilities we don't have a
lack of knowledge we have a lack of
political will and an open sen of an
understanding what this crises are about
and so yes um we can get there and this
war um the situation right now it has
opened many doors we can't backlash um
you know 20 years back um you know
repeating all the same mistakes it was
that were made before or we can jump 10
years ahead and say we are stopping
these crisis we stop accelerating them
we we actually build those safe and
peaceful democracies that are
independent from fossil fuels that
provide real freedom for the people
everywhere talking about the ipcc its
latest report on how climate change
impacts the world was just released what
do you think of its findings
well it's shocking again and again and
again yet most of the things in this
ipcc report were clear a long time ago
these were the things that my grandma
went you know on the streets about and i
think when you stop you know treating
those ibc reports as a breakthrough
report that tell us about a new world
when we have been knowing and ignoring
all that for decades and so i think you
know if anything it's time now to
connect yeah to connect the dots and to
understand the ipcc tells us everything
we need to know to to radically act
um the war financed and funded by a
fossil fuel system is telling us about
the the conflict the war dimension
behind fossil fuels
and i wouldn't know what would stop us
now from from acting as needed
but uh climate change is a global
problem how can it be fought globally is
such a powerful energy player like
russia
is now basically considered a pariah
state how can one push climate change
forward as
a global problem when some countries
maybe have to be shut out of dialogue
just for now i'm i'm less worried about
you know the energies interesting in
russia which is a whole different story
i'm worried about those you know liberal
democracies around the world that claim
to have understood that we're in the
climate crisis and still invest in
fossil fuels still fund those autocrats
like putin still you know defend an
energy dependency on those fossil fuels
and those imports i'm worried about them
where are they right now and while you
know finger-pointing at anyone else
those countries forget that they're
being the excuse for everyone else right
now this accounts for germany that
accounts for many other big industrial
players and if they would have gets they
would get started if they would start
changing the paradigm that we are in if
they started being a leader a role model
in this it would be a completely
different story and it's it's us who
need to look at them right now
and of course and i think that's an
important dimension we're seeing right
now we need to discuss energy
partnerships we need to discuss how
richer industrialized countries can help
others to get away from fossil fuels as
soon as possible we need a
an energy diplomacy that's taking place
but that is focused on what is needed on
the timeline that we have on the few
years that we have left to get things
started do you have any concrete
proposals on that front what liberal
democracies and rich countries should do
uh to help the others go along
i think we need governments to become
clear and
you know honest
about not only the energy
infrastructure that they build
themselves but also the energy
infrastructure that they fund themselves
we see a huge tendency towards you know
big industrialized countries from the
global north to to be all cheery about
climate action to praise their own
targets as much as possible while
funding financing and ensuring fossil
fuel development and fossil fuel
infrastructure in the global south
that's not how it can work out so we
need honesty here we need transparency
here and we need governments to be
cooled out as necessary in their whole
attempts to greenwash themselves to some
climate change heroes while honestly the
the fact speak a different language
while emissions are rising
do you think we are now at a turning
point that this situation does present a
turning point for
a peoples and governments perceptions of
the climate crisis and how to tackle it
i don't know about that but i know that
people right now have the power
to
to fight for justice and peace and
climate justice and all of that has
never been as intertwined as
interdependent as just today we're
seeing that there is no climate justice
without peace and no peace without
climate justice and independence from
fossil fuels it's all out there and if
we want to we can make that the turning
point do you think though that uh people
especially in europe
will understand this and will care about
climate change in the face of the threat
of of war looming so close
yeah again i think it's in our hands um
this is not about you know
claiming one crisis prior to the other
but about connecting the dots and
understanding what are the root causes
of the fossil fuel conflicts and wars
we're seeing not just in the ukraine but
all over the world this is not a new
story it's been out there it's just been
widely ignored especially by western
media and society when we are you know
bold about this
um
and yeah again we are we are able to to
connect the dots and to
to look at
transformative solutions
while supporting in the immediate
situation
but again we're seeing that also
governments and societies have a
tendency to ignore what's right in front
of them that's the story about the
climate crisis for the past decades so
we need to understand that we are needed
here and that we and our understanding
of the crisis and our experience of
people power are needed to make those
changes and to fight for those changes
needed
louisa neubauer thank you very much for
your time
thank you
you